who loves free games you love free games  and if you're an xbox live gold member  you're getting some next month I'm Tony  this is a game spot news update and this  is your games with gold April lineup  first up xbox one launch title rise son  of Rome will be available all month long  Xbox one is also getting Telltale's  choice driven adventure the walking dead  season 2 from April sixteenth through  May 15 on the 360 you're getting the  action and adventure filled Darksiders  from April first through the 15th and  the final Ezio story Assassin's Creed  Revelations from April sixteenth through  the 30th and be sure to subscribe to be  the first to know about all the new  offerings every month that's your April  lineup but you can still grab one of  marches free games evolve until April 15  and speaking of fighting giant monsters  why not check out our impressions of  dauntless  [Music]  you